one
to today's infrastructure services
meeting uh we've got zoom attendees
lindsay mckenzie welcome i have
one apology for lateness and that's from
councillor
arnold cans i'll move that that apology
politeness would be received
executed put their emotionally more in
favor
my apologies councillor anderson's an
apology for maintenance ah
okay radio we've just had uh been
advised that councillor emerson as well
i'll include that with the secondary
i'll put that motion again lives in
favor
thank you right there's no public
forum but we do have a couple of minor
late items
that will be added today and they are
receiving the minutes
to be confirmed from the regional public
transport
uh plan and the attachment of the new
plan
thank you so i'll move that
we received those late items
thank you council lewis put their
emotional list in favor all right
thank you that's passed right
we'll go to the first item and that is
the
minutes of the infrastructure services
committee meeting held
tuesday 7 april
can i have someone confirm that thank
you councillor skelt
seconda councillor sopa put the motion
on that
all those in favor all right um i just
had a quick question oh
yes um item two i
just wanted to make sure that we had
captured this one's gone on for some
time
my understanding of item two was that
we were we had authorized the new title
but also
then the transfer of part of that in an
exchange that had been asked for
last year
item two as in tab six the disposal land
for sale
no this is item two as in recommendation
to cancel about the q
block
number two all right right
sorry i'm still lost here on on where we
item eight and then over the pages in
the minutes of that meeting
number eight oh number eight right
gotcha yep
that's the key yep the q part yeah part
eight yeah
what was the question again so the
question was my understanding of the
beginning of the q park reserve
classification was that it was
because we've been asked for an exchange
of a small piece of that land
with the new owner and that we were
fixing up the title issue
and had agreed that the exchange would
then happen but i wasn't quite sure we
had captured the exchange then happening
in the motion right who on staff would
like to
speak to this i can see heather
and carop so
there's a bit of a question so i there's
two things going on here i think firstly
mr chair
the first is whether the minutes are
correct and
counselor sopa is suggesting i think
that there may be
an omission from the minutes and
if i understand counselor sopha
correctly
her real question is whether the reason
for the classification is recorded in
the
resolution in the minutes
my understanding of the discussion was
that we were
fixing up the classification so that we
could then
transfer the part which we had actually
agreed to last year but
then discovered that the title wasn't
clear
so i'm not sure that i'm not sure that
it doesn't need a c
that says then the transfer that
council's already agreed can take place
mr chair if you'd like to invite
i'm sure welcome heather
thank you mr chair um if i can just
clarify
so yes the process arose because of the
request
to do the exchange of land it was
discovered
that the ownership of the land was not
correct
and so this is what that is and then
once the ownership transfers into
council
then the exchange of land will be
advertised for public consultation as
per the normal reserves act process
so that is why it only sits with that
resolution that you're seeing in front
of you now
right so it doesn't need a c that talks
not actually authorizing that that's
fine i just
just didn't want it to have to have not
encompassed all it needed to
okay great right we're all good
thank you for erasing that okay um
we had a mover uh um sorry i'm
mistook counselor sopa's hand up for a
second
second to council ladder i'm going to
put that motion all that's available
all right that's carrick thank you we'll
move to the
minutes of the extraordinary meeting
of the infrastructural committee held on
11th may
moved council lewis councillor abbott
put the motion all those in favor all
right all right that's karen
right we moved now on to the castig
costello
legacy report and
we're going to have carolyn come and
speak to that
welcome caroline
good afternoon university
since this uh report or since this issue
was last brought to council we've done
a significant amount of uh
consultation with the community um and
the
uh the last being a community workshop
on the 17th of may where we had a
a great attendance um of the community
to come and actually look at two concept
plans of two areas
that we were suggesting that this legacy
could now be
used at we also held a workshop at the
school
that week to see if our school children
in the area
had any preferences to the two
[Music]
sites of preference and they did so what
we have brought
to you today is um two options with the
community's preference
being um duns road and uretti corner
as an area where we can build a pump
track
for the community and all those that are
traveling past
excellent okay we have three
recommendations that the port the report
be
received the second recommendation is
that approve the recommendation that
derekus costello's ninety thousand
dollar
quest which provided the financial
impulse
impetus for the project be spent on
option two
that is the duns road to ready road
corner road reserve
and also recommendation three
acknowledge and give thanks for the
significant work mrs ivey sorry ms ivey
has taken with both the tara community
and council
to ensure the legacy achieves its
intended purposes
right um can i have someone move
yeah i'll move that thank you and a
seconder
right we have that moved and seconded
i'm going to open it up to discussion
council lewis thank you mr chair well i
asked about the open drain and the
preferred option
there how dangerous is that and the
weaknesses in the
it mentions an open drain
um it's i suppose
most of otara has those open drains and
it is just one of
many we're going to try and mitigate
that with a signifi
with landscaping and planting in front
of it to try and
um also shield from view and obviously
create a safety barrier yes
it won't be a need for the specific
fencing no no
thank you thanks very much councillor
clark yeah just like to add what
caroline said
we had a very good meeting with the
senior students
they were very much divided on the two
options until they realized that the
option two actually involved a pump
track and that it would be sealed
because some some tracks that they've
been considered the kids have been
thinking about were actually just
done right and of course that's no good
for doing pump
track work and you've got to be able to
have a reasonably smooth service so that
significantly changed and when it came
to the public meeting we had 45 people
there
all but three went for option two uh the
other three went for the type of one but
they were more focused on having a
walking track around that area which is
what option two is
um so really positive meeting
right any other discussion comments
i think this is great work um done by
both
council staff councillors and the
community so
but it moved and seconded i'm going to
put the motion all those in favor
there's carried thank you
we move on now to the disposal of land
for sale erin do you want to
thank you thank you mr chair councillors
uh brought this to uh your attention in
november
um wakakota you wanted to take some land
of part of the state highway which they
currently have
some council land has been already
repurposed for state highway
in their further diligence they
discovered a light
pole which appropriately should be
situated within
their land um so they have brought it
back and asked
for a further 48 square meters um and so
i'm just asking for council permission
to dispose of the extra portion of land
as per the diagram attached
happy to move the two recommendations
chair second
thank you we've had it moved and
seconded
i'm going to put the motion all those
favor all right all right
there's carrie thank you for that
heather thank you
right we moved now to the southland
regional spaces
and places strategy
and we have miss gibbeling coming to the
table uh thank you mr chair good
afternoon councillors
um i'll take the report
uh as read and i'll just add a few notes
if i may
this is a really significant
collaboration between sports south and
sport new zealand
the three councils and the key local
funders within the southland region
it's the first time we've ever got
together to
plan for our regional spaces and places
with a sport and recreation and leisure
focus and it is a key document that will
help
all the councils and the funders make
informed decisions for the future
investment into sport and recreation
assets
so what we're asking today is that
council consider endorsing the southland
regional spaces and places strategy
and in doing so acknowledging not only
the work that's gone on by the staff
of all those organizations but
recognizing some of those strategic
challenges
that are identified in the cover report
and
the key ones that we've faced include
multi-single use facilities
all requiring renewal no
or limited regional approach to the
planning and management of those
recreation assets for our community and
a real need for the future to focus on
making sure that we're providing more
efficient and effective spaces
for the changing demands of sport and
recreation
the way in which the strategy sets this
out is that it's
a focus on flexibility and
sustainability and it's
best achieved through a really strong
collaborative effort between all of
those partners listed
both central government local government
and our local funders
working together and so for us the
outcome will be
an invercargill better information to
support our decision making
and also a platform by which we might
work with our partners around the region
but also our funders
to make sure that we're making the best
informed decisions for the future of our
recreation assets
so happy to take any questions okay
floor's open for questions uh councillor
lillo
not not really questions uh chair but
um i'm happy to move the recommendations
and and in doing so
say that it's been long on the table
that we've wanted to
collaborate across borders and it's been
great to have
the other organizations buy in i think
having
the report coordinated by sports
southlands played a big part in that
we're looking to celebrate what's
special in each area
you know you wouldn't want to go and
establish for example an ice skating
rink and invercargill because there's
one just a little over half an hour up
the road and and vice versa
it recognizes what's special in each
area
um i think it also ties in with the
reports that
that we've had done on locally on surrey
park
and and rugby park and
um allows us the flexibility that
we've factored into our uh a long-term
plan
i think the first time a suggestion of
this was
murdered was somewhere around 2005 2006
so it's really good to be
at at this point now and and just really
echo steve's point
um from a governance perspective about
how grateful we are for the
organizations that have that have
cooperated and put into this
thank you councillor sopa thanks mr
chair i'm happy to second it and i just
want to say
it's really great to have something this
future focus
that allows strong collaboration on the
table at last
and i particularly highlight the issue
of that high number of single-use
facilities
and our need to design flexible spaces
and really think about the future of air
facilities for the long term
um we all know um how many of those
single use facilities have been built
for various reasons at various times now
need
a lot of maintenance and aren't
necessarily any longer the most
um appropriate way in which sports can
collaborate together so
i'm really pleased to see it here and
the regional planning approach i think
is just a no-brainer it is absolutely
the way to go so i'm happy to second it
thank you the timing is excellent
noting that uh two major infrastructure
pieces are in our long-term plan
and uh supporting use information is
really going to help
us spend wisely so uh it's been moved
seconded
i'm going to put that off counselor
cricket i think you councillor pottinger
just noting that i'll be abstaining from
vote voting due to my association with
sport southland
that is fine that is noted as i will be
with the stadium southland
okay thank you council scott right i'll
put that motion all those in favor
all right against that is carried thank
you very much
thanks steve
all right we move on now to the activity
report right
you're in do you wanna tackle
it is um so i'll take the
reporters read um probably one of these
sorry one of the key things i just want
to highlight is
just draw your attention to the work
that's been happening around the
activation trial
down on debris street um
and just around the fact that that's
obviously work that's been
part funded by the nzta by waka katahi
it's been trialled in a few different
areas around the country similar types
of activation
and so far icc's actually had a
reasonably
positive i guess response to that
compared to
where it's been trialled in in some
other areas so
i guess the suggestion would be that we
probably got the the scope of it about
right um keeping in mind that it is only
a month long
trial um and that we are really pushing
with the community to talk to us about
whether they've liked the idea of having
that that cycle infrastructure
along devron street and whether it's
something that they'd like us to explore
longer term the other piece i'd just
like to draw attention to is just around
the work
on the duns road um cycle path um
just around the fact that we've had some
feedback from the community
really requesting to know why was it
needed that they sort of felt that the
infrastructure was was fine as it was um
just wanting to clarify around the fact
that this the
the way that the pathway was being used
along dunn's road
um it was being used as a two-way cycle
path
um which is in a very simple way it's
illegal
um for it to be used in that way to have
a two-way cycle path where
travelers are going against the grain of
the traffic you actually need to have
that that grade separation between the
traffic lane
and um and the cycle path so
that's the reason we've had to to step
in and do that path so that we can
actually make sure that
the way that it's being used actually
complies with
the land transport rules any question on
the infrastructure component
council clark yeah just a reflection on
the eau de toil downtrode
cycle um i'm also getting a lot of
feedback that has actually enhanced the
safety of the children going to and from
the school as well so that's
been a really positive thing um because
it's a
very large school nearly over 300 now so
um
and that's been a nightmare in recent
times so that's one of the components
around the safety of school is to have
that safety
barrier up and down up and down down
through
thanks for that council cricket council
is over i've just got a
question around the part of the report
that has the
city streets upgrades preferred
contractor issued as downer
in and a relation to the media released
this afternoon that was sent out that
there'll be
um a drop-in session on the wednesday
the 9th
uh between the neighboring retailers and
downer and ourselves and that kind of
thing um i
wondered if that was going to be an
ongoing like fortnightly
logistics meeting as well or is it just
a the public
gets to at this point at this stage
whilst we're still sitting in the design
phase of the project
it's not a regular one we just have a
few essentially ad hoc
dropping sessions to talk to people
about what's coming
um once we actually get into that stage
of being into
the the construction or getting close to
being into the construction phase
then that will become a regular piece
and
with the appointment of downer that's
the work that we're now doing with them
because they'll take a very integral
role
um in that part so we're just shaping
that up with them now
so what what are the renewals that are
happening in east street at the moment
so at the moment there's no renewals
that are happening in esk street what
they are doing is
uh so sorry there is work that's
happening in essex street
yes so that's just around potholing to
look at the ground conditions to inform
the final stages of detailed design
are the neighbouring retailers being
informed
of that as it happens they are
yes and that's on what's happening on
esque street is obviously night works at
this stage
it's a little bit different down street
is different
oh sorry don street sorry sorry don
street is different um where that
is renewals works that that's happening
there and is obviously
affecting the flow of traffic through
the street during the day as well
thank you councillor thanks mr chair i
just wanted to take the opportunity to
say
um that i think the troopers memorial is
looking great
and it is really good to see the
commencement of the work on the senator
and i also wanted to take the
opportunity to just comment on
parts and recreation i see that tribute
has been paid to mr pagan
and his award i just wanted to say
that parks and recreation
are keeping up the legacy very well i'm
getting constant comments about
um about good things happening
and the light displays sorry mr chair um
particularly noted
yes we've now stepped across into the
other areas so uh steve do you want to
make a comment
thank you um no i think we're
we are incredibly proud of the legacy
that robin has left and
we're grateful that he was actually
recognised for his
significant services to parks and
recreation horticulture in new zealand
um we were grateful that he's also been
a great member of our community here in
invercargill
the only two other points i'd like to
make if i can is
whilst we've had the memorial's work
completed through the provincial growth
fund that's
a big piece of work for the team to have
that already by anzac
day commemorations we've also
opened a new 3.2 million hydro slide and
that's going incredibly well
and we've also been able to with
partnership from ilt and the iot
foundation been able to offer
swimming lessons for the bluff community
and makaraiwa communities through that
amazing program we have
and we're working on that at the moment
with those two schools as well as all
the
young people within our own community so
some really good progress
um through the month of april excellent
yes
just the third thing i was going to
mention um the
drilling of the test board for our
alternative water
source have we got any time line on
when we might have had results from that
test ball
um so not pardon me not at this stage
what we've gone is we're just preparing
a proposal to
go out to um providers to actually drill
those test boards
once we've got those proposals back and
we've assessed those then we'll be in a
position to
look at what they've come back around
the time frame thank you
council cricket just one further
question it was about the um
participation with the new hydro slide
so this is your area steve
how do you have the how is the staff
reception
to the groundswell of people coming
through
and we feel it like yeah um
thank you councillor through the chair
with we undertook quite a significant
roster review across the end of last
year and earlier this year in order to
make sure that
when we did have increased numbers of
people come through the pool that our
roster was able to cope it
cope and we have had no issues today
and the feedback from the staff has
actually been really positive because
it's great to have
the place used and full and what we have
noticed is the significant numbers
coming through
from the opening and it's been steady
throughout
and so we're really excited i think it's
been a great investment
in the community asset and we're seeing
that in participation
excellent right any
further discussion council clark yeah
just one issue on the
on the uh alternative water supply
supply and the test boring
and i know this predates you aaron but
um
when you look at the three world reports
that matt russell from south and
district council's about to present to
us the biggest issue we face
by far is a lack of an alternative
supply water
and if we ever want to go through a
debate of having um
whether we opt in or opt out of of the
three waters which will come later this
year
and it's not too far away it would be
helpful to know whether we have
potentially on all 10 towards the play
elsewhere because that changes the
dynamics of that decision i think
take that on notice yeah thank you you
know thanks for raising that
right um the recommendation is that the
committee receives the activity report
can i have someone move it
move to council abbott secretary
councillor sopa
i'm going to put that motion all those
in favor all right against that is
carrick
thank you that comes to the end of the
uh
stanley in public session we're going to
move that we move
into just checking chairman were we
receiving the two late reports
us sorry i thought we did that sorry
well done
fellow cheer
right just before i forget we are going
to
receive the
hearing the minutes of the hearings for
the regional public transport plan
held 27th of april 2021 to be confirmed
and then also receives the new
transport plan can i have someone move
that place
thank you councillor scott seconded
councillor clark i'm going to move
that all those in favor all right all
right against that is carried
thank you thank you councillor
right now that is the end of the public
session
happy to move into into public included
with the exception of mr grant
and mr mr mr mckenzie thank you
have a second uh for that thank you
council lewis
put that all those in favor against that
is carried thank you
members of the public
you